hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's been 14 days since our last
fortnight meetup which now confirms
fortnight updates every fortnight but
now on week 7 of chapter 2 season 2 we
have so many map updates to talk about
so please think about using code Adam
aru to keep the series running then sit
your butt down for 10 minutes and let's
go through all the changes on B our
Island
[Music]
I first checked in with Graham as we all
know he's the key to this whole
fortnight puzzle he's still there and
then I noticed something under the water
at the agency I'm sure you noticed too
five objects in the water perfectly
placed in a pentagon kind of like
doomsday on closer inspection these bad
boys are silos
could they be missile silos are we
looking at the end of season live event
being built before our very eyes I hope
so what do you think these are for I got
to thinking about the five locations and
I have a sneaking suspicion these will
be fast travel points I know it's weird
hear me out so far fortnight has tested
quick travel using a tunnel system in
the toilets and dumpsters what if they
were just tiny versions of island-wide
travel points maybe the grotto will have
one too and we will jump in there and be
transported to the agency just quick
enough for everything to render in on
ps4 that's quite important sometimes
things look like play-doh I'm probably
taking this too far but fast travel
options would improve hot night in my
eyes as we're at the agency I took a
look around and ventured into the
meeting room can you see the change from
last week yes indeed the stolen golden
chair has been replaced with a
substandard desk chair for Midas to lead
the group meetings I love that no one
else gave up their chair for Midas take
the cheap seat boss I'll take a guess at
this and say next week that chair will
be gold hang on we need to put our
detective hats on time to track down the
original golden chair
[Music]
recap four weeks ago the golden throne
was seen in a canoe at the other side of
the agency lake waiting in the bushes
was a getaway vehicle this was a thought
out and planned crime the following
updates are a canoe hidden in the bushes
and the vehicle racing away at breakneck
speeds through salty springs
well this update they have stopped and
they are still in salty springs in the
final house the car has been abandoned
outside with the rope and chair missing
completely go inside the house to track
them both down at the top of the stairs
is the rope and in the bedroom here is
the chair what we need to note here is
that the person who stole this is
already planning their next step reading
something I can't quite make out if you
are unsure about how they feel about
Midas and his crew just look at the
rubbish dump outside now in the trash is
his recruitment picture
could this be Deadpool's new house or
maybe this is the unlockable hidden skin
for the season and a key part to the
plot of chapter 2 hit me with some story
theories below let's try and break this
case wide open next let's go to Ferris
Bueller's house with the beach front
view last time we met up the red Ferrari
was being rescued by a crane when
disaster struck and they fell straight
back down in a heap together last update
I said this I hope we see another bigger
crane built to pull this crane out and
you never know by the end of season 10
we could have 100 vehicles piled up here
and look what happened exactly as I
foretold the Russian doll falling crane
scenario happened so epic games I
challenge you yet again bring over
another huge crane even bigger than this
one and keep this disaster cycle going I
don't think it's gonna happen I need
your help to add a little bit of
positive peer pressure to epic games
right do the right thing epic in the
comments below let's jet back hether
next update Oh check this out whilst I
was frolicking on the shoreline I
spotted this Pokemon themed campsite
I'm not sure if this is new or not
because I don't think I've ever been
round here except for that time I used a
lightsaber that went well
anyway if you look at this spot it looks
just like one Ash Ketchum would stay in
what was the tagline again oh yeah
goddess blow to maul please keep an eye
on this spot let me know if something
happens that I miss
[Music]
here's a change from last week I
neglected to show you let's write that
wrong this instant have you visited the
plane-crash which began the whole
chapter two saga take a closer look now
you'll notice nature is taking this spot
back slowly encroaching onto the plains
pieces wings and fuselage again this
will take months to update and evolve
and there's even pieces missing here -
who the heck would be taking pieces of a
plane as an extra note remember the
crustaceans that began to multiply in
this area of the map well these guys
have now begun to take over this island
and the plane - I've spotted four of
these critters on treasure chests on
stools and even in the plane itself
could they be combining to make a metal
crustacean creature or are these cute
little buggers harmless the only way to
find out is by pressing subscribe right
now sorry
Oh before I forget there's new items in
fortnight this week the Kingsmen
umbrella and the crash mats please hit
me with some myths about a next myth
chaser episode which is all about those
two items if we get some good ones we'll
try 100 person myth chaser meetups again
hopefully this will help us socialize in
a time when social distancing is a real
thing
let's check out pleasant Park I've been
keeping an eye on this place for one
single reason and it's pretty stupid but
I like it in the center of the soccer
field is a chest it has slowly been
tipping over since this thing opened I'm
tempted to stream here for six hours and
pretend it's an event oh my god guys my
screen is shaking
don't worry not my style whilst we're
here have you noticed the items in the
open bunker look again it's the missing
pieces from the aeroplane which I
learned today is pronounced airplane in
American English because it flies in the
air in traditional English we say
aeroplane because it's aerodynamic every
day's a school day here slap like now if
you didn't know that let's move on now
it's time to check on the iron man he
sat dormant for months but once the
Christmas update gave him sweet new
spectacles he changed his head moved and
last update he stood up and began to
walk around the map cut to this week and
his current position he's full-on
marching somewhere on his mission but
where is Rowdy Roddy Piper man going
well let's follow his path and it leads
all the way to this location hidden
within the trees is a mess of iron
piping could he be going here I do think
he is the bigger question is what will
he do when he gets here I reckon he will
build a partner for himself or maybe a
pipe dog let's see who can call this
what will happen when the iron man
arrives I'll be lurking in the comments
below
so I also took this further I decided to
look further around the map and looked
for more iron items I was thinking back
to how much I like the rock family and
that had a man a woman and a rock dog
that didn't find each other for seasons
well look further on the shoreline and
it's already being built
look what's at here waiting for
seemingly ever look at his face only a
mother could love this is another
character that needs a name please
fortnight family do the honours Oh segue
speaking of characters you guys named
let's check up on Gandalf keemstar
Jerome the genome good no good
[Music]
our Gandalf is still here with his
majestic floating wizard like powers but
look at the bunker he's in massive
changes this week where the hell do I
start well there's a dance pad on the
floor for the usual challenge we all
have to complete each season but the
real news is the honey pots on the wagon
I think this is the start of the misfit
bears attempts for global domination in
the meeting room the Bears now have a
map and five spots have been marked out
hmm are they linked to the missile silos
at the agency or are these locations to
hide honey pots Winnie the Pooh
crossover confirmed do me a favor and
keep around these locations let's try
and figure it out together before the
next update if I scratch that I checked
for myself there's nothing here today
but judging by the locations they shall
be those honey pots anyway back to the
bunker it's someone's birthday down here
check out the balloons
they're everywhere oh okay shut the
front door
have you seen what is happening outside
this secret bunker graham has unveiled
his plans to free his twin brother his
minions are already in place around the
misfits complete with interactable
telescopes what's interesting at these
spots is the sound of bees check it out
and we all know what bees are famous for
their honey there's something going down
with those honey pots we also have
explosive containers we have CB radios
and we have doughnuts
this is serious the rescue of Gandalf is
coming soon so now is a very important
question
are you team genome or IU team misfit
there or maybe your team thick someone
should totally include a poll to answer
that burning question once and for all
right this instant
so a little housekeeping to end the
chair truck and pallet trucks have not
moved in the slightest this week it's a
bummer but okay the bunker remains
completely closed as it has since the
start of chapter 2 and the most
surprising lack of update is at the
yacht this should have changed this week
and it hasn't which has me thinking it
may be linked to the Deadpool update so
keep an eye on this it could be
absolutely epic okay so that's us done
and dusted for another week on screen
are the leg ends those who are kind
enough to use my code to buy something
new in the store they then send me a DM
on Twitter to get their name up here I
say this a lot but I mean it thank you
for choosing my code and supporting this
kind of video I truly appreciate the
creativity you give me thank you kindly
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade go
wash your hands and avoid people I'll
see you online
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]